Berlin Kreuzberg: in die Jahre
gekommenes Alternativviertel
und kultureller Schmelztiegel.
Vor allem kulinarisch hat der
Berliner Süden viel zu bieten.
Und damit sind nicht nur die
Dönerläden an jeder Ecke gemeint.
Das Goldies hat sich innerhalb von
neun Monaten zu einem der
beliebtesten Läden gemausert. Dabei ist
das Goldies eigentlich eine Pommes-Bude,
aber eine mit Anspruch.
Bei uns ist eins zum Nachfrittieren mit
Rinderfett und das andere mit Erdnussöl
– so kann der Gast dann entscheiden. Oder
wenn er ein vegetarisches Gericht hat,
kriegt er in Erdnussöl, wenn er ein
Fleischgericht hat, kriegt er in Rinderfett.
Stammkunden, die Fleisch essen,
kriegen ohne zu fragen Rinderfett.
Auf die Idee mit den Pommes Deluxe
kamen Vladislav Gachyn und Kajo Hiesl
während ihrer Ausbildung. Dass die beiden
in Sterne-Restaurants gearbeitet haben,
merkt man nicht nur an ihren 14
verschiedenen Soßen.
Das ist unsere Ente Peking,
das ist gezupftes Entenfleisch.
Die Entenkeulen beizen wir zwölf Stunden
in Salz und Zucker,
damit das Fleisch saftiger ist. Dann
schmoren wir die im Ofen.
Und dann machen wir aus der Haut
einen Crumble und das Fleisch
zupfen wir einfach nur runter,
dass sozusagen keine Knochen
oder Fett dabei ist [sind]. Dann kommt
eine Hoisin-Pflaumen-Mayonnaise dazu,
die sehr … leicht süßlich ist. Und dann
halt die knusprige Haut,
die … wo wir das Fett sozusagen
nochmal extra backen, aus der Haut.
Und den Gästen schmeckt es.
Eine Tonne Kartoffeln verbraucht
das Goldies in der Woche. Neben
der Pekingente sind die Pommes
mit schwarzen Trüffeln besonders beliebt.
Ich bin ja Niederländer, und deswegen
habe ich schon einen ziemlich
hohen Standard für Pommes. Ich
vermisse das auch manchmal so in Berlin,
weil die Pommes hier nicht so gut sind.
Und das ist halt der einzige Laden,
wo die Pommes eigentlich noch
besser sind als in Holland oder Belgien.
Eine Portion kostet zwischen 5 und 10 Euro
– alles natürlich auch zum Mitnehmen.
Wir lieben Pommes, aber es ist jetzt nicht
… wir würden nicht für Pommes töten.
Und es ist so: Wir haben halt nach was
geguckt, was es nicht gibt.
Genau, das war die Sache. Weil sonst
immer Pommes irgendwie bei
einer Currywurst daneben als Beilage
ist [sind], oder beim Burger.
Und wir haben halt überlegt: Was gibt es
wirklich nicht in Berlin?
Ja, und darauf kamen wir halt auf die Idee.
Wem das immer noch nicht genug
goldgelbes Vergnügen ist,
für den gibt es sogar Pommes-Kunst.
Im Keller wartet eine Videoinstallation mit
Pommesgabeln – selbstverständlich frittiert.